and season four favorite scene well
actually I think that the farewell
prison scene with Peter with Tyrion was
one of the nicest scenes we've had
together it was beautifully written and
just lovely to play and poignant and
pretty sad actually to do that because I
don't even know if I'm gonna get the
hook up with him again and he was such a
so beautiful to work with him and so
that I would say that would have to be
my favorite did you think when you
because obviously you told Tyrion that
show you was often you got on the on the
ship and then she turned it for the
trial and then of course you'd mentioned
that scene though which was a beautiful
scene a farewell scene but obviously you
saying to Tyrion I'm not gonna help you
out what did you kind of what were your
feelings on your character in those
moments I thought I was torn because on
one hand level I was like all people are
gonna be really you know think that bran
is betraying him on one hand but on the
other hand I think he's being totally
true to his character and so I wasn't
but I don't you know so he wasn't
between himself and I think Tyrion
respects that and that's kind of why
Tyrion likes him because he's that's
what he's like himself he sees himself
in him and and look what happened to the
guy who did take on the mountain so you
know I think he did the right thing
because that hopefully he'll come along
and get Tyrion out of a scrape somewhere
down the line I mean you mentioned of
course that ethic fight the Viper versus
a mountain what it although obviously
you knew is going to happen what did you
think when you saw it on screen how they
brought it to life I didn't know that
was going to happen
I try not to read the scripts if I can
help it the bits that I'm not involved
with because I like to we have a throne
tonight at home and I kind of like it to
unfold I was that was more shocking than
anything for some reason the way it was
set up
and the you know it was more shocking
than than what the wedding and so I was
and there was just was the horrific way
he died and so kind of just so yeah I
was shocked as when many of us I'm sure
have you found going back to shoot
season five compared to all those
previous four seasons that you've been
involved with
that's tricky because that could be
giving away what I'm doing in season
five it's hard to speak because it's
different let's put it this way it's
different than my new normal kind of
environment
LeBron so it's actually it was nice to
shake it up and I am I can't give away
too much more than that
I believe how interesting is an actor
too because obviously we've got this big
body of work by george RR martin and the
TV show draws on that that is also
something different in itself isn't it
how much how interesting how fun is if
he was an actor to kind of go away from
that canon those books in a way it's a
very unusual job the fact that you've
got that body of work and that so that
kind of depth of following already and
you've got the standard of the work and
yet you've got these two you know Dan
and David have done such an incredible
job of bringing it to screen and giving
it their own life and having George's
trust with that so to be involved and
it's a phenomenon that the job is a
phenomenon it's an unfolding phenomena
so there's not going to be I'm not going
to be involved in another job like that
there's no you know you can't put it in
a box and it's carrying on at the moment
it's a moment it's carrying on for me
but that you know that's the other thing
about it it's like you have to just kind
of enjoy it while I was there because
anyway it's only got two maximum three
years left so I've just been grateful
that I've had five seasons at it
you